scientists have figured out the best and
healthiest way to produce plants
it is a cutting-edge grafting technique
that was enhanced over conventional
procedures and published in a nature
Science magazine
grafting is when you take the root of
one plant and attach it to the Chute of
another plant people have been doing
this for a long time to help apple and
citrus trees grow better and stay
healthy but there was one type of plant
that they thought they couldn't graft
they're called monocotyledons or monocot
plants
that's a fancy name for plants like
bananas date palms and grasses like
wheat and oats but a scientist named
Julian Hibbard from the University of
Cambridge and his team found a way to do
it they transplanted unique tissue from
a plant's seeds onto two plants of the
same species
the two plants grew together as one
plant as a result of this
to ensure that the roots and stem were
interconnected and could share food and
water they even utilized special lights
the new grafting method worked on a lot
of different types of monocot plants
like bananas pineapple onions and even
tequila agave the scientists also tried
grafting a wheat plant to an old plant
which could protect the wheat from
getting sick this new way of grafting
could be especially helpful for a
special type of banana called the
Cavendish banana
most of the bananas we eat are Cavendish
bananas but they can't grow from seeds
Farmers must continually reproduce the
same plant because bananas are unable to
Bear children on their own
this uniformizes the bananas which is
undesirable because if one banana
becomes ill they could all become sick a
banana plant can be shielded against
ailments like Panama Disease by grafting
a more resilient plant onto it but if we
graft the Cavendish bananas to healthy
root stocks the bananas will be able to
avoid getting Panama disease and stay
healthy
that's all for today guys
I hope you learned something new about
Innovative grafting technique and how it
can help plants stay healthy don't
forget to like And subscribe for more
fun science videos